people that like make up stories about
me they make up stories about me and my
brother they do all these weird things
and I turn to my brother I'm like can
you believe what this person said Can
he's like yeah they're all they
all have mental illness most people have
mental illness it really becomes
apparent when you have such a large
platform and you become a victim of all
the noise coming at you and the things
that they say so fascinating and you're
right like how do you have time to do
that I have people that like research me
create these conspiracies about me and
all these long threads they're like I'm
this investigative journalist underc
investigating Leia like I'm really not
that interesting you know investigating
her it's like you have nothing else to
do